shouting from the top of their lungs
women in the southwestern nigerian town
of owo condemned the recent attack
scores of people were killed
at a church while the sabbath was going
on some government came and they killed
a lot of people children hundred men men
and the return has returned into money
this sunday that's why we are here we
are here as market women we are here to
communicate with the poor forward we are
here to say that enough is enough
in a region unfamiliar with religious
conflict this grieving husband is facing
life as a single father of five
his wife took two of their children to
church only the boys returned home
it's just like somebody have two hands
and they caught one hand
police say the gunman who attacked the
saint francis catholic church disguised
themselves as congregants
streaks of blood still mark the church
walls with undetonated improvised
explosive devices on the ground
the local hospital is still treating
survivors but supplies are running low
forcing families to rely on the kindness
of strangers
victims of the attack still coming to
terms with what they saw they didn't
come to steal everything they didn't
have to kidnap anybody but they just
they all agree with that kill and
destroy africa's most populous country
has grappled with severe problems of
violence and criminality in the north
for more than a decade but millions may
be forced to flee nigeria if the
internal conflict moves south
no group has claimed responsibility for
the attack as seven days of national
mourning continues
chilean wolf al jazeera